shit
the neon demon is directed by Nicolas
winning revenant stars Ella Fanning Jena
Malone Christina Hendricks Keanu Reeves
among others and is the story of a young
girl who moves to LA she wants to be a
model and much to the horror of models
that have already been in LA for a long
time that are trying to get ahead
she plows right through them and into
the spotlight which causes some problems
Drive is probably his most accessible
movie maybe that and Bronson and I
suppose the pusher films are a little
more accessible as well but with movies
like Valhalla Rising and only God
forgives he showed himself to be a very
experimental filmmaker which is
something I admire I like directors who
make films that are ballsy that are
different and with the neon demon
Nicolas Winding Ruffin without a doubt
has made his most fucked up movie
comparing it to only God forgives it is
a more straightforward narrative there
is more of a story there's a lot more
dialogue Ella Fanning is very good as
this aspiring model Jessie a lot of
people are starting to feel very jealous
of her which causes a lot of animosity
there's her makeup artist played by
jenna malone there are two other models
who have been in LA for a longer period
of time and they're starting to get very
upset about all the attention she's
getting there's the owner of a seedy
motel she stays at played by Keanu
Reeves who has some strange motivations
of his own and there are so many
different ways to interpret this movie
in fact I'm still reeling from it there
are aspects of this film that are
visually stunning and brilliant
obviously the cinematography is going to
be very good if you've seen any of
referenced movies you know that this is
easily the best cinematography I've seen
all year that the use of colors is
extraordinary
the soundtrack by Cliff Martinez is
euphoric ly amazing I mean one of the
best of the year easily visually this
movie is an A+ it's stunning it's
beautiful it's just that at times it is
very much so an exercise of style over
substance and if you've seen any of
reference films then you probably
expected that going
in is that really a problem though it
depends on who you are if you like films
like that if you like films that use
visual storytelling to make you
understand something to make you think
about something then you're going to
really enjoy this film but if you want
more answers and more of a
straightforward story and a
straightforward thorough line narrative
then you're going to be disappointed
because this movie's fucking nuts the
last third act of this film is insane
and I won't spoil anything for you
unlike other critics who for whatever
reason feel the need to ruin this ending
because I had it ruined for me by a
professional film critic who decided to
choose their excerpt for Rotten Tomatoes
explaining exactly what happens in the
third act of this movie which really
pissed me off
I'm not going to do that to you guys
because I'm here for you but it's insane
there's a lot of crazy shit and it's the
kind of ending that's designed to shock
you it's designed to make you go like
what and it will appalled and disturb
many but when you really examine the
statement that's being made about the
way people can become Beauty obsessed
and the way people can just become so
horrible because they're so obsessed
with their own vanity and just how far
people will go to get to the top this
movie examines all of that and very
visually disturbing ways Keanu Reeves as
I said is in the movie and he's very
good in the movie and I liked his
performance in the movie he was very
entertaining but then his character gets
taken in this strange direction that
felt totally out of left field and he's
just sort of dropped and I was just like
you know what happened with that for me
personally despite the fact that Ella
Fanning I thought was very good in this
movie luminous scary just really good my
favorite actress in the movie actually
was Jena Malone I think she steals the
entire film she gives the most daring
performance she does some stuff that's
stuff that's just that's what I'll say
but she and I really respect her because
I haven't seen an actress all year
give her performance this just just out
there just like what you didn't you did
that you actually did that good for you
that's kind of fucked up but you did it
like okay and where this movie fell
apart for me was the same place that
only God forgives did whenever ref and
tries
to fetishize whatever depraved act he is
depicting on the screen he did that very
much so and only God forgives with an
over-the-top torture scene and this film
he does it again with sequences that are
so over-the-top and unbelievable that it
had a older man sitting next to me who
at the beginning of the film went Shh to
his wife audibly going Oh for heaven's
sake near the end and part of me really
respects that side of Raffin for making
a film that has so balls-out insane
towards the third act but the other part
of me is like what does this really do
for your story or is this just you being
a pornographer and that's a direct quote
I'm not insulting the man he has
referred to himself as a pornographer he
has said he is someone who films things
that he wants to see and you know you
got some fucked up fetishes buddy but if
I'm being honest with myself I was
consistently riveted by the neon demon
it's a visually stunning movie with a
lot of great visual metaphors that stick
with you and I want to see it again I
want to see it again
right now if I had the blu-ray I would
pop it in right as soon as I was done
filming this and watch it it has staying
power it has the ability to become a
cult classic in fact I think it will
become a cult classic it is a movie that
a lot of people are going to be bothered
and offended by and if you are not a fan
of strange different art films just stay
away if you like a more straightforward
narrative stay away but if you like
films that are different that do take
chances that do take artistic risks then
the neon demon might Entertain You
I'm going to give the film a B+ weird as
shit movie but I kind of dug it
eventually I will probably do an analyze
video similar to only God forgives and
drive I have to see it again I have to
see it again and again and again
probably before I can do that just like
I did with enemy but I would like to do
that for you guys guys thank you so much
as always for watching check out the
film if you get a chance to this weekend
it is weird and different and I think
that that should be supported even
though some of it goes a little too far
as always guys if you like this you can
click right here and get stuck mine eyes